Thallium, because it is heavier, has two different
so-called
oxidation states. It can react with one atom
of chlorine per
thallium, or say three, and the different
chemistry between
thallium-one and thallium-three. Thallium
salts are very
poisonous, and there was quite a notorious
case some years
ago when a technician at some company, who
turned out to
be mad, was discovered to have been poisoning
many of his
colleagues with thallium and so, but it is
not a widely used
element, apart from a few materials that are
used. There is a
rather nice red material that is made of thallium,
which has
the rather unromantic name of KRS-5, this
is mixed bromide
and iodine with thallium which is used as
windows for many
infrared experiments. But because thallium
is so poisonous,
one has to be quite careful about handling.